hi in this video I'll be talking about
microtubule dynamic instability so
before going into what is dynamic
instability and what is a usage of it
what is the significance of dynamic
instability let us try to understand the
types of microtubule microtubules
present in the cell so cells could have
different varieties of microtubules
stable microtubules and unstable
microtubules think about a situation of
growth cone think about a situation of a
Celia or the sperm tail which has which
is supported by the microtubule
architecture so they give rise to the
rigidity and the structural support to
these kind of structures but imagine a
situation where a cell like neutrophil
or monocyte has to squeeze itself
through the narrow capillary epithelial
cells to reach to a tissue space of
where inflammation has happened in that
kind of situation you need a lot of
cytoskeletal rearrangements similarly
you need your microtubule to be very
flexible need to be stabilized and
destabilized in a rapid manner in order
to make this process happen
imagine cell division when you need your
spindles which are made up of
microtubules to pull your chromosome
they are length need to be shortened and
then lenden in point of time in order
for the cell division to happen in
proper situation if the microtubule
dynamic instability is not there if
microtubule is always stable then these
kind of dynamic process cannot take
place inside the cell so we need
stability in microtubule for certain
kind of processes whereas certain kind
of biological processes like cell
division or cell migration requires
dynamic instability of the microtubule
so microtubule depending upon the demand
depending upon the need can change its
dynamic city can make it more dynamic or
can make it more stable and different
sales have their unique strategies to
make to make the microtubules more
dynamic or less dynamic so we know that
already
that microtubule is made up of tubulin
dimers alpha and beta tubulin so we can
purify the tubulin and from this
purified tubulin we can allow them to
polymerize in vitro and with
high-resolution microscopy and with high
resolution with high precision
microscopy we can follow the dynamics
over time and scientists have done these
experiments what they found is under
certain conditions the microtubules the
labeled microtubules what you can see in
this movie are not not at all stable
follow the arrow and you can appreciate
that the microtubules are growing and
shrinking over a point of time in a
cartoon manner we can understand that
several micro if we if we look at a time
frame microtubule would grow shrink and
change their morphology and change their
dynamics so this dynamic city which
exists exists in terms of microtubules
shortening and lengthening is known as
dynamic instability of microtubule so if
you track their motion over time and
calculate the length of the microtubule
in this time bout what we would see is
there are several events where
microtubule lengths dramatically
decreases we turn those event as
catastrophe
there are also events where there is a
recovery of the short of the microtubule
lane as if the microtubule length is now
gradually increasing and those about we
call it
rescue phase so these are the features
of the microtubule dynamics all these
things hint us that there could be a
critical critical concentration of these
tubulin dimers based on which
microtubule polymerization kinetics
could vary so there exists a critical
concentration for microtubule assembly
now if our given concentration which is
the concentration of tubulin present in
the solution is more than the critical
concentration then it would undergo
polymerization and increase in the
length of the microtubule whereas if the
concentration at a given time point is
less than the critical concentration
then microtubule would kind of t
polymerize and get destabilized and
short the length would be shortened now
inside a cell the situation is very
different because the concentration of
tubulin inside the cell is very high
about 20 micro molars so that is way way
beyond than the critical concentration
of microtubule polymerization
so that is why inside the cell
polymerization event or microtubule
limiting events are actually favored not
only that there are other guiding cues
such as microtubule organizing Center
which help these microtubule to be
organized and help in polymerization
inside the microtubule organizing Center
the central our matrix consists of like
gamma tubulin ring complex which help as
a nucleating factor and also help to
stabilize the microtubules as a result
microtubule grows in a smooth fashion
there is another kind of kinetics of
microtubule movement which we call tread
milling the thread milling can only
occur when at one end of the microtubule
filament the concentration of tubulin is
less than the critical concentration and
other side the concentration is higher
than the critical concentration and if
you understand the video so far you
would understand
then at one end there would be
polymerization and other end there would
be D polymerization and as a result if
the rate of polymerization and
depolymerization kind of equalized then
there would be no net increase in the
length but as a result it looks like the
microtubule is making a treadmill like
movement so this kind of specific
movement is known as tread milling now
microtubule dynamic instability is very
important in context of several diseases
like cancer in cancer the hallmark of
cancer is dramatic increase of cell
division the tumor cells divide rapidly
vigorously and you know that when the
cells divide they need microtubule
dynamics right specifically they need
the spindles to be contracted and and
also expanded in in in order for the
chromosomes to move to opposite poles
but imagine if you give specific
reagents which would block these
dynamics and stabilize microtubule don't
allow the microtubule to destabilize in
that situation the cells can no more
divide and that's it that could be an
effective therapeutic strategy against
cancer cells because cancer cells need
to divide rapidly in order to make that
tumor mass now if they can if their
microtubules are too stabilized they
cannot divide any more so they cannot
make rapid division and build up the
tumor mass so this kind of medication is
also based on the fundamental concept of
dynamic instability of microtubules in
terms of cellular physiology dynamic
instability is one of the most important
and incredible phenomena I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
please leave your comment below because
that gives me the motivation to make
more videos thank you
you